Speaker 1: OK, let's hear from a few more
people today, a real mix of calls you can
join via discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Let's go back to Mobile, Alabama, and try
again. Mobile, are you. Are things functioning?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me? I can
apologize for the last time I had the wrong
keyboard. Push and talk. Apology accepted.
My question to you is, have you ever lived in an
area that wasn't necessarily a liberal leaning
area? And if you have or if you haven't, how do
you how do you suggest people who maybe are more
on the liberal side cope with living in an area
where the vast majority of people do not share,
maybe even like 60 percent of your views?
Speaker 1: Right. Yeah. So I've not
permanently lived in such an area, but I've spent,
you know, cumulatively months and months in such
areas, typically a couple of weeks at a time.
My recommendation is find a community that does
match up more with your views. So, you know,
at one point in one place, I found that there was
kind of like a left leaning non super religious
Jewish community group. And I met some interesting
people with that who mostly shared my views
through the living liberal organization. A lot
of places will have, you know, like a drinking
liberally chapter or that type of thing. So so
the way I would cope with it would be to just,
you know, even if you're in a place that might
be sixty five, thirty five conservative like,
you know, Utah is really, really conservative
in Salt Lake City. And I think in Provo there
are still a bunch of liberal people and liberal
groups that you can kind of make your community.
So I think that that would be my approach. I
mean, in a really rural area, it could be very
tough, like in rural Idaho or something like that.
I don't know whether this is even feasible, but
in most larger towns and smaller cities, there is
a population there that will be aligned with you.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm from northwest
Florida and this area of Alabama,
and it seems like a huge portion of the population
just lives in a different reality in some cases.
And and my question further to go further
is how do you see and do you see any path
for a progressive kind of thought to permeate
these areas and grow or ever take hold?
Speaker 1: You know, I it's funny you you
mention northwest Florida because we have a
bunch of great friends in northwest Florida,
in Pensacola, associated with the entire
ring of fire, you know, Ring of Fire Productions
and Mike Papantonio, Faran Cousins. And that
entire team is in northwest northwest Florida.
And so I've been down I've been down there. And
it's a it's a red area. But even Pensacola has
these blue enclaves. Now, part of it is it's a
big it's a big sort of legal area for mass torts
and mass towards lawyers tend to lean left. So
that's kind of like a predetermined community
there. But even there, there is you know,
you got your hipster cafes and you've got
your stuff. I mean, it really is spreading.
Speaker 2: It's helpful to think of it in
that way. I just wonder if we'll ever see
the policy dictated by our local leaders.
Speaker 1: Well, that's going to depend on
getting activated and voting. That's a different
less of a cultural question and it's more of a
voting question. Yeah, but I mean, I hope so.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. All
right. Mobile, Alabama. Great. Glad
to be able to put that together